hello and welcome to another one of my
dr sandler talking talks
this one i am responding to a question
that came to me through eu today
a very good question
and i really like this question in part
because it opens up a lot of different
possibilities this is something that i
could actually use as a staging ground
for an entire
hour course lecture if i was if i was
teaching an ethics class which i may be
doing soon um i also like it because it
represents
it's represents a starting point
that is
prevalent in our culture this notion
that who are we to teach morality or are
we to impose our morality on other
people
if we're teaching some sort of
ethics in school
aren't we privileging some
particular point of view over against
others so here's the question i was
actually asked
because we operate on a personal level
in regards to moral value judgments
should athletes be taught in school
and my very short answer to that is
yes precisely because
we operate on a personal
level in regards to moral belly
judgments
now that may seem a little paradoxical
particularly
if you're used to the notion that the
personal is this kind of sacrosanct
space and we must never interfere in
other people's values we must never push
our morality into the sphere of other
people's inferiority onto their
consciences
but if you actually look at social life
and you actually look at what we do
in social settings
that falls apart as nonsense very
quickly doesn't it
because as soon as somebody starts
violating certain basic norms um
you know i'm not thinking of things like
what you're wearing but
not hitting people
not stealing you know the things that
all the great religions and all the
great moral codes have had something to
say about you know
not using violence against other people
not
lying
to other people or about other people
not slandering them
not
losing your temper in very bad ways not
taking other people's things without
permission
all those sort of things
we are tempted to do and children tend
to do them and children come up with
justifications for why they do that
so do people who are at a fairly low
level of moral development
sometimes people who are at a higher
level of moral development too when the
moral reasoning gets screwed up when
something goes haywire in the process
so what i would like to
think about
tonight
is really two things i want to look at
this from the perspective of the
individual
and then i want to think about the
social setting
i think if we look at both of these
we realize that yes in fact not only
can we teach ethics in school in the
sense of it's a possibility not only can
we teach ethics in school
in the sense of it is legitimate to do
it is permissible i think that actually
we arguably have a moral duty
to teach ethics in school
that's that's a pretty strong thing
and i'm going to argue for that as time
goes on
um think about moral development as it
takes place in individuals there are a
lot of different scales of moral
development
ranging from those in ancient philosophy
already plato and eris model talk about
this the stoics talk about this
the
epicurean tradition actually has
something along these lines and
distinguishing between different types
of goods and those who pursue these
goods
and it's often not so much a question of
how perfect are you but how how
unscrewed up you are how much have you
actually realized human nature the
potentialities that we have
for flourishing for living the good life
and living a life that is not just good
in the sense of being
good in the eyes of other people useful
to them not harmful to them but good in
that you're actually orienting yourself
towards
happiness which includes your
relationships with other people it
includes how you think about yourself
how you orient yourself
we also have all sorts of you know
medieval philosophers and modern
philosophers who've reflected on this
one very common way of talking about
this if you bring up the notion of oral
development people think of kolberg and
his scale which at the low levels i knew
i knew my interview i had some some
concerns about the higher levels as do
quite a few other theorists feminists
have some problems with it for one
reason
at a discourse emphasis like you're
compromising problems for other reasons
alistair mcintyre's other problems
but let's say we step aside from that we
just think of this basic intuition
that there are certain levels of moral
development and what advances those
levels of moral development it's the
basis on which a person carries out
moral reasoning on which they carry out
their practical reasoning what ought i
to do what what may i do what would be
good for me to do what would be bad for
me to do
and at a very very low level
it's based solely on notions of
punishment and reward
and you know little children are like
this at many times although you know
children do um in most cases also have a
sense of empathy
that develops very quickly and that you
can you can harness
but some people remain at a very low
level of pure punishment and reward
their
and it's not just movie villains there
aren't many people
who remain like that in and out of the
prison system i taught a few of them
interestingly i didn't teach many of
them
many of the men that i had discussions
with about ethics but actually we're at
you know higher stages
but there are some people who are like
that
and then you can move to higher stages
and actually it is an advanced to start
caring about what other people think
about you and to do things purely on the
basis of pleasing other people that is
an advance besides beyond the pure
solipsistic
you know narcissistic
attitude of others are there solely to
to serve me
and i will only do
things that i that people think i want
to do on the basis of punishment reward
that's an advance
and we can go higher and higher
we can talk in terms of moral principles
we can talk in terms of
uh recognizing the rights of others we
can talk in terms of
having empathy or sympathy
or
a sense of conscience there are a lot of
different ways in which we can we can
speak about this we can we can talk
about taking others into consideration
and carrying out a sort of utilitarian
calculation where we try to do what's
best for the most people and you know if
it ends up harming a few people
but it ends up benefiting the most
people sometimes that's that's the thing
to do that's higher up than just saying
screw everybody else i'm going to do
what benefits me
it's not the highest level but it is a
higher level
so we have this variety of moral
perspectives
and you know when students come to a
classroom
they have a variety of moral
perspectives
they don't all see things the same way
here's where it's interesting
one of the things that you want people
to do
is to
for a variety of reasons is to rise from
lower moral levels to higher problems
from a purely
self-interested perspective do you want
to live next to somebody who might kill
you in the middle of the night if if
they feel it would be to their benefit i
don't think so
so
do you want to you know turn out a
generation of kids like that probably
not
so you're going to want them to have
some level of moral development this has
been a part of education from the very
beginning
it's really a bizarre thought and
something peculiarly
western
late modern to think of education as
sort of morally neutral
or not inculcating values because every
every other
every other
notion of education that you're going to
find out there
in all the cultures that's that's part
of the point of education
um
how do people progress how do they rise
to different models well you know it's
madame you can say if you don't do what
i tell you i'm going to knock the living
you know tire out here
how far is that going to get you that
actually you know may
change them that makes them descend to a
lower level
that's appropriate for those who can
only be handled in such ways and there
are people who can only be handed in
such ways but it's not going to teach
that question it's not going to elevate
them very much
what about teaching
well you know if you're actually
teaching people things
you're teaching ethics
if you're teaching them that they should
behave in this way or even if you're
teaching them you want to take this
moral theory which i'm not pushing on
you but you ought to at least take it
seriously enough so that you can pass a
test where i ask you about what do
utilitarians think or you know
what what is a formulation of kant's
category categorical imperative or
what is a virtue
you're teaching them
and that may in fact
result in these aha moments that
students have that are very
unpredictable but we love to see when
we're educators
conflict is also an important part this
is something where i think colbert
actually
was really onto something
he saw that if you want to develop
from lower levels to higher levels you
can't just push people you can't just
tell them here's a scale of levels get
from here to here
they need to experience conflict they
need to actually experience
seeing other people's perspectives that
don't jide with their own and having
that cognitive dissonance
and then that that preps them sometimes
for being able to be jarred out of a
lower position to the beginnings of an
upper position and then then you can
start working with them um also very key
models you know and this is part of why
the
i'm going to discipline you into into
respecting level 5 or something like
that you know i'm going to
discipline you into respecting uh
conscience i'm going to discipline you
into to being a good person
not that effective
because what sort of what are you
actually modeling you're teaching
something you're teaching people that
you can use violence
as a tool to get them to conform
better models are those that actually
embody certain moral values or certain
moral theories
people who have virtues
you know actually if you want somebody
to
to learn the conscience perspective find
somebody who's a conscient and actually
lives it out
you can do it with very you know
mundane things as well it doesn't have
to be high level theory because we have
all sorts of ethnic that we live up
now let's think about the social setting
let's say you try to make the classroom
a morality free zone morality neutral
zone does that work
not for long
i mean some people enjoy it those who
want to oppress others
or tease them or bully them love that
sort of thing because once you introduce
that sort of
morality free zone you no longer have
any way to criticize the video
and even imposing some sort of
discipline
even if it's purely arbitrary is already
adopting the moral standard this is okay
this is not okay i will punish you
for this and i won't punish you for that
you're sending messages no matter what
you do
if you're allowing all sorts of things
to go on you're sending a message that
that's okay
if you refuse to teach ethics because
you consider it to be
something absolutely sacrosanct or
something so um
beyond the pale you can't you can't
teach it
you're actually sending a message about
right and wrong in doing so
you're sending a message that's usually
pretty incoherent to the students that
are encountering it and sometimes
educators feel like they're liberating
students when really if you ask those
students
they do not feel liberated at all they
actually feel someone oppressed by it
so you know it is important to think
about what moral messages you're sending
why not send an actual coherent
moral message you know adopt a
thoughtful attitude towards ethics
teach it
don't teach your dads here's the one
ethic that you have to adopt
this is the only one
all the others are terrible or reducible
to it
teach a whole bunch of them but but
teach them actually adopt those
positions and argue for them and make
students apply them in cases and make
the students engage in conflict with
each other and argue with each other
that's how you
have students grow that's how you
thoughtfully do this
brain subject matter experts
philosophers
there's plenty of other people in other
fields who do ethics as well but i think
philosophers are really at the core of
it
and i think actually to get people who
have a historical background
not just
you know not just doing meta ethics or
something like that or some some
obstruction
but actually have studied the history of
ethics so they know a lot of ethical
systems
teaching students how to develop and
grow how do you teach them well part of
it is by learning by doing
again that's where these things come in
model it for them bring them into
conflict with each other not conflict
where they're punching each other at the
nose but where they actually have to
provide
justifications arguments claims
information sources where they have to
engage each other where if somebody
adopts a terrible position the other
people will hold them accountable and
say that's a that's an awful thing to
say why are you saying that
that's teaching them actually how to
develop and how to grow provide them
with resources
show them where they can go if they want
to know more about virtue ethics show
them where in the library they can find
books about this there's an incredible
hunger out there
i'm finding this among young people
who as
generations have been
effectively deprived of the opportunity
to react against some sort of a
system
that you know would be imposed from
above and would actually give them some
some meat that they could
chew up and then spit out
they've also been deprived of the
opportunity to talk about these things
because there's been for so many people
kind of a ban on bringing these things
up
but younger people do want to talk about
these they want to think about it but
they can't think about it effectively if
they don't grow if they don't develop if
nobody teaches them how to do this in a
thoughtful way if if we don't do that
we're effectively
sending them a message
let's just do things from a knee-jerk
perspective and then say we agree to
disagree and let the chips fall where
they may and that does not really help
anybody
the other thing that i think is really
key
is to introduce them to this
understanding of super individual goods
that there are certain things that go
beyond
the individual and cannot be
made actual just in an individual
but are also important for the
flourishing of individuals
order itself as a good this is a notion
that is really this is you know at the
core of ancient medieval even a lot of
modern
ethical theory and political philosophy
and it has dropped out
of our discourse
harmony the notion of harmony or concord
what does that actually mean does that
mean we all we just all get along we
like each other or is it something more
substantive what does it require that's
something we should be talking about and
teaching about
what does it mean to actually create
fields of opportunity for other people
is it just so simple is to say back off
and let them do whatever they want
or does it require something that's a
super individual good that benefits
individuals but that goes beyond them
social life itself
you know we are social beings we are not
beings meant to exist in a vacuum and
our good development requires it the one
thing that i will leave you with that i
didn't put on the blackboard that i i
always like to leave you with a question
are there some activities are there some
goods are there some practices that
cannot be enjoyed
by yourself as an individual but yet
contribute to a full human life
that would be part of
something that would be recognized by
higher levels of moral development i
think there are and i'll leave it up to
you to think about that in that question